welcome to this video blank fed and matt
from from from the UK and let's check
their costs are sky-high a nice yeah i
think this is sam an acquaintance of
kingscrusher i think so let's see the
regular main lights laughs probably i
recently played 23 year I'd had a good
position let's try that again just
ignoring that I'm upon down this may be
95 immediately was better but okay it's
not a lot of problem okay very
interesting way to play this but it it
makes my bishop really strong so I'm
quite uncertain if this is really good
okay um if i go night and 95 you met but
didn't see heavy form
now that I can just retreat that right
before I can retreat and I don't need to
wow wow that looks really bad
who how does he survive this I mean I've
got rooked you one coming b7 hangs got
fantastic pair of bishops so I guess
root g1s right it makes it very
difficult for him to to move anything
and I'm threatening stuff like Bishop g4
quite quite crude but crude and
effective so Bishop to g4 he has to move
the night but he can move that but then
I have check on b5 right so isn't this
just winning winning the house
yeah the problem with the movie 5 was
that after d5 all the light squares are
opened up and we see this whole thing is
coming on the light squares rukon d1
Queen on d5 bishop on g4 he has weakened
the light squares so I'm considerably
that it got tricky and I simply
overlooked this this very very simple
move how how embarrassing I was really
thinking I'm winning wow wow wow how bad
can you play really I cannot even if the
Queen oh no just just so embarrassing
and any other move that Bishop g4 would
have been fantastic and Bishop e3 for
example he has no move I just started
Bishop g4 he resigns but he doesn't Oh
terrible terrible
have no Queen move i have to take on da
am checking and believe he absolutely
should not get away with that but he
does I should just Bishop e3 years no
move here he cannot castle and we look
at this afterwards unbelievable hello 95
I simply overlooked the movable Jeff
I still have some compensation him which
gives some indication how good the
position was but yeah ok so I'm we
ruling this to g5 here we go let's open
up the whole thing it's got this this
green side this Queen side play just
going to be important but not much I can
do about it so let's see I can play look
everyone but it might be might be too
late for that let's just go here be too
weak v1 stops the whole thing
yeah let's stop the porn check so check
let's go here
hmm where's he going them Knight to f5
or what where to exactly see if I can
approach them can I achieve okay I
wonder if I somehow does he just want to
draw this position maybe he maybe thats
it's this idea check okay so we try
something okay van going here then
Bishop e3 is coming so i probably have
to go here
Jeff hmm I don't know did that really
helped him so he's out for this check
here possibly but I can also go get one
now attacking f7 at the moment the B
porn is not posing any particular threat
what a bad game him probably really bad
from both sides okay so let's go e 6 not
spend an hour here that should be quite
good if he takes but should be six wins
outright and this also looks a bit
strange many dependencies and blacks
positions blacks position check in at
stake here so how to do this it will
maybe come to h6 I guess maybe get I'm
warning maybe get this get this on okay
seven so chicks chicks that wins right
95 Luke f7 I mean wins so let's do this
see if I can take the take the B porn
now i think i can take it actually or a
45 it's also not not particularly bad
but let's take that take the beep on
before it does something terrible to me
okay check no es g6 that's stupid again
okay I wanted to put it on g6 that was
the idea but yeah
thought it's better than none right on
only six now I can actually bring up
come on bring up the upon check black
forfeits on time yeah what what is
stupid move in the opening a bishop
g-form and its really if I do Bishop e3
or like he I just Bishop e3 he resigns
this he has no move absolutely no move
and because he cannot castle he cannot
move the night yeah any night move his
check is a disaster so what is his move
I'm threatening Bishop a seven here and
I'm connecting rooks so now it is
pretend I'm threatening Bishop g4 I just
over just over this thing and that
completely I completely forgot about 95
yeah just entirely your tech and then my
next move is also bad but ok it was
probably because I was ranting too much
why don't I play this it's just it's so
much better when i played this is this
is more ridiculous than Bishop g4 even
check I mean I still have compensation
for the porn this is resistor which is
the sick thing but now the stupid stupid
way to play really check Jan yeah yeah
I'm better again this point is not
really not really dangerous it's stopped
now um what is actually interesting is
this this this opening phase here and if
he goes he really should play something
like a six-year like here I go efore and
I don't know Bishop before or something
like that that looks fairly normal I
think white has very decent compensation
because he gave me the bishop am
basically for free but this is not
simply no
not a good idea because of d5 this is a
huge difference let's say between let
let's just assume um I know it makes no
sense but let's make a waiting move yeah
and white would go efore which is not
good and then e five this is a huge
difference if I'm playing d5 now he can
actually just stay in the center yeah he
doesn't need to take on d5 we can just
stay if i play on c6 if i take on c6 you
captures with the beep on now my bishop
is not a good piece but with e 5 d5 now
this will trade those two pawns will
trade and might that long mama bishop
will get a huge long diagonal if it is
that and this is this is some yeah
probably hit better than the game
actually but still not good i will get
c4 back and have a very nice position
with two bishops yeah like II form a
four and then I'm regaining the pawn and
here after after the treaty especially
um here is that that's basically just
over here if I go be should be three he
has no move yeah let's say Queen c7 to
continue and then what is strongest rook
see one maybe yeah whoops see one just
trying to get the pawn if he goes be
five and say here he's just not able to
to defend this at all and that was one
of the split was super stupid yeah not
seeing Bishop c95 I was really thinking
he just resides now so I'm very very bad
what I would I did here okay well thanks
for watching